اذا حركه المواصلات العامه في باريس واجهت
شلل جزئيا في الوقت الذي يتصاعد فيه غضب
المستخدمين لان الخدمات اصلا ما تزال
تعاني من التقليص منذ جائحه كورونا اذا لا
تزال تعاني من ذلك العربيه التقت بعضا من
سكان باريس في يوم الاضراب هذا لتسالهم
على من يقع اللون في ما حدث على العمال
المغربيين ام على الحكومه الفرنسيه
[موسيقى]
على الضفه الاخرى اضرب عمال مترو انفاق
العاصمه البريطانيه للمطالبه ايضا بتحسين
الاجور وهو الاضراب الذي ياتي بعد فشل
محادثات مع هيئه النقل في لندن قالت هيئه
النقل لانه من المتوقع ان يستمر الاضراب
حتى صباح غد الجمعه واوسط سكان بتجنب
السفر عبر مترو الانفاق والبحث عن وسائل
بديله هذا التحرك الاخير هو اخر حلقه في
سلسله اضرابات نقابيه الهدف منها واحد
تحسين الرواتب والمعاشات تقاعديه وظروف
العام لكن الحلقه المقبله من الاضرابات
ستكون صعبه للغايه على البريطانيين ان
حدثت فالعاملون في قطاع التمريض في عموم
البلاد صوتوا لصالح تنظيم اضراب وطني
حسبما اعلنت نقابه الكليه الملكيه للتمريض
ار سي ان وحذرت النقابه من ان اكبر
مستشفيات انجلترا ستتاثر بالاضراب الذي من
المفترض ان يبدا قبل نهايه العام الحالي
وبينما لم تحدد النقابه طبيعه الاضراب بعد
الا ان كثيره بالتاكيد سيطالوا المرضى
الذين يعانون اساسا من لوائح انتظار
قياسيه واضطرابا في العمليات والمواعيد
دانت الكليه الملكيه للتمريض ظروف العمل
وتدني رواتب الممرضين والممرضات خلال
الاعوام الاخيره وطالبت بزياده الاجور
بنسبه 5%
بسبب نسبه التضخم الذي قفز باكثر من اثني
عشر بالمائه في سبتمبر وقد اظهر تحليل
نشير مؤخرا ان رتبه ممرض يملك خبره انخفض
بنسبه 20% من قيمته الحقيقيه منذ عام 2010
[موسيقى]